these are very difficult times for the
Hollywood screenwriter in the old days
it took oh about two hours for the boy
to get the girl and nowadays the boy and
the girl are making love under the
titles so where do we go from there
Harry
tonight we honor some of the
screenwriters who have solved this
problem the nominations for Best
Screenplay based on material from
another medium are Airport screenplay by
George Seaton
I never sang for my father screenplay by
Robert Anderson lovers and other
strangers screenplay by Renee Taylor
Joseph Bologna and David Siegel Goodman
mash screenplay by Ring Lardner jr.
women in love screenplay by Larry Kramer
and the winner is the winner is rain
Lardner jr. format
at long last a pattern has been
established in my life at the end of
every 28 years I get one of these so I
will see you all again in 1999
welcome to Hollywood miss miles thank
you I'm very frightened that being here
sorry--but closes my eyes but I'm very
happy to be giving an award to a writer
right right listen me you've not only
been nominated for your performance in
Ryan's daughter but I understand you
already have a couple of Oscars in your
home in London my husband Robert thank
you
what did he what did he write oh yes he
wrote
he wrote dr. Zhivago a man for all
seasons ear I'm I'm going to start with
the nominations now sir the nominations
for Best story and screenplay are five
Easy Pieces story by Bob Rafelson and
Adrienne Joyce screenplay by Adrienne
Joyce Jo story and screenplay by Norman
wet slap love story story and screenplay
by Erich Segal my night at Mons I've
seen that one stories story and
screenplay by Erich I could runner Roma
Wilma
Pattin story and screenplay by Francis
Ford Coppola and Edmund H North the
winner is Francis Ford Coppola
I know that mr. Coppola would join me in
thanking you very very much for this
award I personally would like to thank
Frank McCarthy and Frank Schaffner a
magnificent producer and a magnificent
director and I'd like to say one word if
I may about the picture I would hope
that Patton is not just a war picture I
would hope it's a peace picture thank
you very much
you